first of all, I'm very happy to be here.
where are all the once upon a time fans?
you guys, this is like the highlight of my con every year
so let's started with these fabulous people
I wanna bring up first the executive producers
of once upon a time
let's bring out Eddie Kitsis and Adam Horowitz
Hi guys, how are you?
Good, really beautiful and scruff, I love it
up next, we have the fabulous Jared Gilmore
Who plays Henry Mills
He's gotten so big, I can't stand it
Up next is the villainous and also sweet
the wicked witch, Zelena
Rebecca Mader
we have the beautiful and winsome Belle, Emilie De Ravin
we have the handsome and charming and also the villainous at times
Josh Dallas who plays Prince Charming and David Nolan
we have the amazing woman, who plays Regina and the evil queen
Lana Parrilla
Love that outfit, love the apple
Up next, the beautiful and fierce, Emma Swan
Play by Jennifer Morrison
and last but not least, the roguishly handsome
Hook
Colin O Donoghue
So, Hi guys
Okay, so let's start with Emilie
let's get happy and sunshiney and let's go to Emilie
Hi honey
Rumple has put Belle through a lot of stuff through the years
and she keeps believing
I wanna know what is the draw for Belle with Rumple
what it is about him that makes her go
I'm gonna keep believing no matter what he does to me and my unborn child right now
Yeah, good question
I think that she and well I guess, we all could see it towards the end of last season for the first time
she's acknowledging and realizing that part of that pull is
him being kind of a bad guy
she likes that
even though, deep down, yes
she sees the good in him
she sees a wonderful person and a loving person he can be
but that darkness, she likes that
there's a side of that that definitely pulls her in
and why she's stuck by him and hung around to a degree
I think she's struggling with that quite a bit
Lana
We saw an amazing arc for you this year. There has been
Regina was redeemed
and then she lost the great love of her life
her soulmate
and now she's split
she's put herself in two
and she's become Regina and the evil queen
my question is how, how complete is the split?
is Regina fully good?
and the evil queen fully evil?
or it is just still a mixture in Regina?
because we like that little bit of mischief in her
Regina is still sassy
she's not gonna lose her sass
we like our Regina sassy
The question I actually asked Adam and Eddie as well
cause I thought is, she just now this pure , you know, light being kind of, I guess you would say
And they said well no not really
cause she's still sassy and
that's Regina
She's sarcastic
and that's why we love about her
so she's not gonna lose that
but, the evil queen is slightly different than she used to be
I think
I would think that Adam and Eddie agree
she is now without a conscious. so she's pure evil
and a lot of fun
Regina is desperate to
really, you know, be this hero and be happy internally, like deep down inside
and that's really what she wants for herself
she has this beautifull family now
and, umm
and her sister
so, it's going be an interesting journey this year
to see how the two versions of Regina
and well, the evil queen and Regina, sort of.
co-exist
Josh, speak of duality
you got to play, two different people, but you got to be yourself
and then also your evil brother
so, what was that like, for you getting to show that other side of you as an actor?
it was great, you know, it was a chance for  charming to see everything that he didn't want to be
or everything he didn't ever wanna become.
and he wanted to have a relationship with his brother, and he always felt a connection with him
and I wish, you know, he wishes that he could have got
to know him
but, that just wasn't the case
But I, you know, his brother was a reminder to him of everything that he wanna to avoid and stay away from
and not become
Colin and Jen, this is first request directly from the twitters
they like you, somebody head needs to go on somebody shoulder
and somebody put an arm around
this is my question for you guys
at the end in your final scene together, umm, there was a wedding dress
I think I know what this is
it's in the shop window behind
it's, umm, on the set. It's always been there
it wasn't specifically put there it's just the dress
that was in the window but I don't think it's
a wedding dress
well, I think we can all agree
if it was Emma's wedding dress
it would be red and leather
hey Jared
yes
first of all, you've grown and makes me very  uncomfortable, cause you're now taller than me. that the first
second, umm, Henry kinda spread his wings this year.
he rebelled a bit, in my opinion,
what in your mind has he learned this year, about the importance, his importance in his family and where he stands?
does he feel that he is a vital part of it, where does he fit in?
I think now that Henry is the author
umm, he's gained that, thing that "I am a hero now."
and my way of helping people is by being able to give them, their stories
and help them figure things out.
and, umm. I think Henry has
found his place
and he believes that now, he is a part of the heroes
and I think he likes it.
he loves it
Rebecca
Zelena has had quite an arc this year
what in your opinion has changed her more
becoming a mom?
reconciling with her sister?
or being loved and love being hades?
of those three which is the one that is the biggest thing that made her go I'm turning a corner
can I pick all of them?
-yea?
yea, all of them
I mean, I think it's a plethora, it's a cacophony
if you will love everything
I mean, it's a lot happened all at once
in terms of breaking down Zelena's heart, you know?
I think, the reason she got pregnant was for horrible reasons but then it ended up
really changing her
I don't think she really expected or understood that having a baby meant having unconditional love
and I think that melted her heart a little bit
it was also hard for her to
accept and believe a man can actually love her
because she has such a rubbish life
and then all of sudden, her sister gave her her trust
which she really quite frankly didn't deserve it
so this like these three people that loved her even though she didn't really feel like she was worth it
and I think that changed her in a really powerful, fundamental way
and it's been really fun to play
Hades is gone, I had to save Regina as you do.
and I'm carrying the baby and I'm really enjoying, you know, this season so far
I can't wait to see what's gonna happen.
Adam and Eddie
I notice that Zeus, he stepped in and he changed Hook's fate
Can Zeus somehow intervene in all eternal matters?
I feel like, that was a one time only,  Zeus interference
He could've given me back my hand
Why don't I magic back his hand? I keep wondering that
Do you really want two hands?
Nah, I like the hook, I'm into it
This is for Jen and Lana
Emma - Regina's connection is one of my favorite parts of the show
you guys have spent a lot of time helping each other, loving each other, and encouraging each other,
towards accepting every part of yourselves
how would their relationship evolve now, that Regina possibly has no ill will towards Emma
and the evil queen has nothing but ill will towards everybody.
Gosh
these women has grown so much over the years and they've become best friends
yeah
and umm,  it's such an admirable relationship. And,
I'm curious to see
I know Regina and Emma are gonna, well, I don't know anything actually, do I?
Adam, Eddie, do we know anything?
well, we know plenty.
well, we know plenty, but we don't know what's coming
I mean they're working together and I think Emma has really helped Regina get to this new place in her life for
she is, you know, always she's been constant battle with this darkness
and Emma has saved her many times, and has been a great friend
and vice versa
and I see them continuing down that path
now the evil queen is just another entity in itself
so I have no idea, how she's going to respond or react
I think it's gonna be complicated for Emma to navigate, because she wants to believe in Regina
and she wants to believe that good can win
but then she also knows she needs to protect everyone she loves.
including, you know, everyone in her family, and that includes Regina
so it's like, how do you separate the two mentally and figure out where to draw the line
and then how do you do that in a way where you're not betraying the trust you've developed with this friend for so long
so, I think it's gonna be compliated like it always is.
but fun, and an awesome journey.
Hey Colin and Josh, we love your bromance
We also love our bromance
- I love our bromance, too.
do we have any more?
Do we have some more fun times coming with the two of you guys?
Eddie, Adam?
I would say there's going to be some fun times to be
had it just depends what your interpretation of fun is
so, is he still the Hook we know and love, is there a change with him, since he's comeback from the dead?
I think he's still the pretty much the same Hook
I mean he's sort of, trying to
you know, now that they know that it's sort of
true love with Emma
and Hook, it's sort of, they're trying to figure out , how to navigate being together in that sort of world now
and, umm, yes, so at the minute he's still the same Hook
but, I think we might find out a few things about his past.
we may
I can't tell you everything today
But no, there's a little bit more of Hook's past
that we delve into and hopefully
some surprising secrets that have been harbored